Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you’re watching
the TodayIFoundOut Youtube channel.
In the video today, we’re looking at why
it is that we drive on parkways and park on
driveways.
To most people the fact that we drive on parkways
and park on driveways is rarely pondered upon.
This only comes to mind when pointed out by
particularly cringe-worthy comedians, who
no doubt are also likely to muse on why the
Royal Mail service delivers "post" while the
U.S. Postal Service delivers "mail".
But once pointed out, it does all make you
wonder...
As it turns out, there’s a perfectly valid
explanation for why we drive on parkways and
park on driveways- the majority of words have
been around longer than cars and many have
seen their definitions evolve over time, as
parkways and driveways have likewise evolved.
For example, if you went back to the 19th
century, you'd find one of the definitions
of “park” was:
To put strips of lawn down the centre or along
the side of (a street, the main streets of
a city)
Before this, the term had originally been
applied to enclosed private game preserves,
sometimes around large estates of the aristocracy
in Europe.
For instance, in the Charter of Friðuuald
of Surrey written in 1260 it says the following,
which I’m not even going to attempt to pronounce
correctly: "Bitwiene ðe shrubbes and Wine⁓briȝt
goinde adun norðriȝte binuðe ða parkes
gate."
Later, it began to refer to any well-kept
grounds around an estate, then to any well
landscaped grounds, whether private or public.
Shortly before automobiles became a thing,
“parking” referred to the act of planting
trees, shrubbery and other assorted foliage
while the term “parking place” could generally
be understood to mean an area designated for
these various flora and fauna- essentially
an area where plants were put not for agricultural
usage, but simply to provide a pleasant place
to soak up nature.
This is why the word “park”, even today,
can refer to a designated large, potentially
wooded, area filled with greenery and sometimes
wildlife.
As for when the word “park” and its various
derivatives became associated with a stationary
vehicle, this unsurprisingly occurred in the
early 20th century when automobiles were becoming
more popular.
You see, prior to the mass adoption of cars,
for reasons that will soon become clear when
we explain the origin of the term "parkway",
the area around and sometimes in parking places
(areas of greenery) would occasionally be
used to temporarily store horses and the carriages
they pulled, if any.
When cars began to appear on the roads, the
practise of using these same type of parking
places to store them naturally continued as
well.
One of the first such references to such an
area specifically designated for cars occurred
in Lion's Share by Arnold Bennett, published
in 1916: "Audrey's motor-car...was waiting
in the automobile park outside the principal
gates."
As such, the term “parking place” came
to mean a place where one would store a car
when it wasn’t in use, regardless of whether
that area was particularly well landscaped
with plants or not.
(Additionally, sometime around the mid-20th
century “park” added a new definition
to mean the act of bringing a car to a complete
stop in such a designated area.)
Going back to the late 19th and early 20th
centuries, as previously alluded to, many
cities in the States began to construct parks
filled with trees and the like to contrast
the bleak, depressing walls of concrete that
cities were quickly becoming filled with.
This provided citizens with a nice area to
relax and enjoy nature and was generally thought
to improve health.
In the late 19th century, a landscape architect
called Frederick Law Olmsted (the man who
designed Central Park in New York and helped
popularize the idea that people's homes should
have grass lawns, we’ll have more on this
in an upcoming video: Why Do We Have Grass
Lawns?) suggested that these types of parks
should connect the surrounding cities and
towns (in his original proposal connecting
suburban parks with parks in the cities)-
what he originally referred to as “pleasure
roads”.
The initial idea behind these proposed thoroughfares
was that they’d be used for the 19th century
equivalent of commuting to and from the city,
whether via walking, riding a bike, horse,
or in a carriage.
To make the journey as pleasant as possible,
the roads would be “parked”, or flanked
with trees and greenery, to make them more
scenic.
So, in a nutshell, they were narrow, exceptionally
long parks that allowed for relatively fast
travel between the suburbs and cities.
As with parking places, these “parkways”,
as they came to be known, were later repurposed
and constructed mostly for use by automobiles-
becoming more about fast travel than the scenery.
So the fact that you drive, not park, on a
parkway makes complete sense in this context.
So what about the fact that we park on driveways?
According to the Oxford English Dictionary,
the definition of a driveway is as follows:
A private carriageway for a motor vehicle
alongside, in front of, or leading to a house,
garage, or other building; a drive.
This definition has more or less been the
same for about a century and a half, dating
back to the first known instances of the word
being used in the 1870s.
What has changed, however, is the size of
driveways.
Back in the 19th century, a driveway in the
context of leading to someone's home was often
a much longer road than is typical today,
at least outside of cities where people had
driveways.
While houses with smaller driveways existed,
the idea of them being used to store a car
did not because cars didn’t really exist
yet (at least not for most, more on this in
another upcoming video: The Husband and Wife
Team That Gave the World the First Car and
the First Road Trip That Saved It From Obscurity).
Driveways at this time were just used for
walking or riding a horse or carriage up to
your home, with the latter two generally stored
in a barn or stable if you had one, or a field
if not.
Even when cars became a thing, driveways weren’t
necessarily used to store or “park” cars
because, again, there was often space off
the road, such as a barn, ample land, and
eventually dedicated garages.
It was only as driveways became shorter and
shorter due to the rise of suburbia and cars
(and home ownership) became accessible to
the masses, who didn't necessarily own large
plots of land and trappings like buildings
to store cars, that car-sized driveways began
to be commonly used as a place to “park”
ones car.
The rise in popularity of manicured grass
lawns in the late 1940s also made this even
more of a necessity so as not to ruin one's
lawn if you were to pull off the dedicated
tiny driveway.
Today, many who live in a country with relatively
large plots of land still primarily use their
driveways for driving, rather than parking.
But for everyone else in suburbia, outside
of a potential garage, one's driveway is probably
the only place on the property to park a car.
So as with most things that seem to not make
sense when one lacks data on a given subject,
the fact that we park on driveways and drive
on parkways is perfectly reasonable once the
context is understood.